all right Zion
how's it going Zion no where'd you grow
up where are you from originally
so I was born in Berlin Germany
um I moved here when I was four years
old because my parents divorced
and then uh when I was in first grade
my uh my mother lost custody of me so
she kidnapped me back to Germany for a
year
my dad came and found me
um
now to begin with like both my parents
have had addiction problems their whole
life my mom is a cocaine act and my dad
is a drug alcoholic
and slash drug addict
so I mean you can imagine it's not
always easy you know it never has been
um
and with the divorce and everything it
became hard my mom tried to live in Los
Angeles for a while but then she left
back to Germany to become a [__] rock
star
when I was 10 and that kind of ruined me
for a little bit
so
then all I had was my dad I don't know
he was always at work you know he did
his best he tried to be a good father
um now now I don't really talk to him
anymore
um so my uncle would kind of Watch Me
growing up when he was always at work
until I was like 17 18 by that time I
left home but
my uncle was all has always been a meth
addict as well so that was a great
situation either
um Everyone's an addict in your family
yeah pretty much every man in my family
has been an addict my grandfather too
died from hep C and uh and diabetes from
sharing needles you know
so
I've always been abused as a child
I still love my father but I don't talk
to him anymore you say abused abused in
what way
like like my mama jokes what I mean
for like
like sometimes I get locked in a closet
for hours you know
um I remember one incident
my dad's kind of like a musician or
whatever
so you actually got a studio out here in
downtown right
I don't know if you've heard of like
those those fire escape tunnels that
they have under there like the old
school fire escape tunnels render
Studios no so there's some like very old
school buildings out here in downtown
L.A and they have these fire escape
tones downstairs and they go all over
downtown yeah
um he would lock me in there
it was scary as [__]
but like that's just some of the stuff
you're how old I was like eight
sometimes and then he stopped doing it
by the time I was 14 because I was
strong enough to fight back and be like
[__] you you know
um
and then by the time I became like 16 my
uncle
my uncle passed away from drug abuse
um
they they tell us the OD on fentanyl but
he was never a fan on attic he was just
a meth addict
and the strangest part about it is um
started dating this girl
and uh
she liked because my uncle being a meth
addict he got kind of involved in like
the local gang in the neighborhood
started selling drugs out of our house
so the government put a gang injunction
on property right and all of a sudden
this girl comes around
and uh
it was just kind of strange has the
timing and how she came around and
started dating her yeah she got sober
for three months which was amazing you
know that's the longest he's ever been
sober we're all really proud of him
gain some weight
and she this girl had like five kids and
uh
started like hearing stuff about
that her baby daddy was from like a
rival gang you know and all of a sudden
you really have some meth and uh
tells us the reason he relives is
because uh
she accused him of being a pedophile
you know and I know it's like
he took care of me as a kid you know and
I have a girl cousin she loves him he
was never [__] pedophiles and he
next day like
we find him dead on a cardboard box
in a house
owned by someone nobody knew you know
it's very strange
she showed up the day of his funeral
like in front of my house with glasses
on and just like
just stared I came out and told her like
what the [__] do you want
she didn't say nothing
did she finally said go get your grandma
I want to talk to her so I go inside and
come back out with my Grandma she's gone
it doesn't make any sense you know
that really [__] bothered me
um
you're using as well now yeah
I have two children
sorry
I haven't really talked about this
[__]
hey
I was actually doing a really good in my
life for a second
Believe It or Not uh my dad's a light
technician
he's worked at a House of Blues in
Hollywood
which is now closed down obviously
Avalon exchange on Spring Street
a lot of places um
by the time I was 18 I started getting
into lighting with him
and um
as you can imagine that that scene
didn't help with my drug abuse
you know there's always been drugs
around there so
just kept down spiraling and down
spiraling and
I mean
it it used to never be opiates and I
think that's my biggest problem it used
to just be like
of the meth here and there like a little
bit of acid or you know just
experimenting and
I got hit by a car at 38 miles an hour
when I was 17 coming home from work
and so you know it gave me a bunch of
Oxys
and morphine hydrocodone and
I knew how heroin felt because I tried
it once in high school
so
by the time they stopped prescribing me
all the pills I just
it was cheaper it was better
started doing that
kept trying to work in the entertainment
business or everybody else [__] her out
with drugs you know
yeah I hope my family's problems and
trying to be a father to kids when I
can't even take care of myself
I think that was the hardest part
and uh
eventually one night I got off of work
at like 4 AM and
I couldn't find heroin anyway so
someone gave me some thought no
next day I tried to do heroin and it
wouldn't take the withdrawals away
anymore
now I'm like
I'm 22 years old
I haven't seen my kids in like two years
oh
didn't even out of jail
can't get off this [__] [__]
I think I'm at the point where if I have
to [__] kill someone kiss me though
but I probably will
It's My Life
with the family you had it almost seems
like you were destined to get involved
in drugs
yeah
it's weird though like my grandma
he's the only person that never had a
problem with drugs or alcohol she's just
happy the way she is
I wish I could be like that you know
remember my children also sober
I've actually never did excuse me I've
actually never dated a girl that's been
on drugs surprisingly
and
I can't even wrap my head around that
but uh
yeah it's just
I lost everything
this is [__] [__]
um
every time I [__] been a jail it just
gets worse you know I can't get a job
anymore
so I have to turn doing like bad stuff
on the streets you know like crime
committing crimes hurting people
stuff I want to do
and of course I get hurt too because
what comes around goes around you know
it's the worst thing you've been through
it's obviously I've been through
on the street
hello
I really don't like talking about this
[__] man
I think what you know it's like really
bothered me all my life is that
[__]
when I was a kid
my
my grandma used to take me to the bar
all the time in Germany you know it was
a normal thing a lot of kids go with
their parents to the bar
and um I guess a mutual friend there had
like offered me a wire stripping job
here
so of course I said yes you know I want
to make a little money
to we're stripping wires all day and
but that was all cool and
he's acting like a fatherly figure or
whatever you know and Patty me on the
back and then
it went from Patty me on the back to
[__] like
pretty much like
message me you're gonna grab my ass and
[__] I hit him with the original and
that was all
thank God like I knew better and I was
old enough
but
that may not be like
as serious as other people's experiences
have been but
that's something that's
[__] on my head
try to kill myself a couple times
hug myself like three times
we tried getting clean Suboxone so many
times
so hard
I mean
I know it's probably [__] because
if I really wanted to I would right yeah
I don't even know what I want
that's the hard part
I don't know if I even want to live
anymore
what are your parents doing today are
they still I don't even know
I mean yeah there's my dad's still an
alcoholic my mom's still a drug addict
I don't talk to you there then
I mean usually I just buy and sell drugs
you know
but uh
seriously I went to jail
and my car got impounded and I got out
but
a friend of mine helped helped me out a
lot got me out
paying to get 3 800 to get my car out of
the impound
and basically made a deal with me like
I'll pay for your car to get it out of
impound I'll give you my old Chevy Tahoe
so I signed over my car to him and he
gave me a Chevy Tahoe which is really
nice you know
you let me live at his house for three
months
and then his wife would feed me and take
care of me
and then after three months like like he
was teaching me how to fix your car and
we'd both find like finished fixing your
car the cylinder that engine cylinder 3
was misfiring so
we fixed that car started working I got
back on my feet and um
the radiators had a crack in it so it
started overheating
and uh eventually my head gasket blew my
car got towed
and now I'm [__] again you know
I can't hard to sell drugs without a car
you can't get a job no
um
so I kept trying to sell drugs but
without a car you know
[__]
it's hard to get around and I'm more
vulnerable
where do you stay at night
anywhere I can on the bus
like for these past couple days I try to
stay on the train and
they kicked me off the sheriff's kicked
me off
so I ended up here and I've been still
up sick for three days
they're really dope Secrets like you
can't even walk you know
so I couldn't even get myself up to your
back
so that ten dollars you know that
[__] saved my life I wouldn't be able
to talk right now
oh that I gave you before you started
yeah
I really appreciate it
her
yeah I mean
if I could right now like if I had a
phone I'd probably just call my drug
dealer and get a [__] ton of dragons um
you know I'm sorry yeah [__] ton of
dragons and stuff you know but I don't
want to keep doing this [__]
can't go to rehab anymore because my
insurance doesn't want to cover me
but I'm like over 50 times
I don't know what to do anymore in my
life
I can see the other side you know it's
right there
yeah no I can I can do it
I don't know if I want to
I don't even feel like a human anymore
are you friends
I don't know what friends are
I mean my best friend stabbed me three
times for three times a Coke you know
I think that's like the loneliest I ever
felt in my life
no one helped me
it's in the parking lot of Eagle Rock
Recreation Center cross street from our
high school
I knew his kids he's first grade man
no hesitation
left me a [__] die there
no one [__] helped me
if you were just walking by me ignoring
me
bleeding out everywhere
some homeless you finally gave me super
glue and I [__] just super glued my
[__] mood shut
and dried it with a lighter
let's hear it right now
being alive
getting dope sick
tell me what it's like being dubstep
on opiates for fentanyl right horrible
um
it's almost like
Nikki the the road starts getting really
good like everything starts snowing like
death and [__]
you start noticing all the nasty [__]
more and more and more
and all of how [__] up people really
are you know
and uh
you just started noticing how evil this
place is
it starts feeling like it's not really
Earth anymore you know like you're in
some kind of hell
and then you start getting the physical
withdrawals hot sweats cold sweats
your muscle spasms to like electricity
jolting through your body
[__] screams of Agony here
knowing to fix it no one helps you
it's miserable
every time
I just want to kill myself
either that or get high you know
and I'll try to I'll try to push myself
to go like
to go a couple days without it see if I
can do it never [__] make it
um
it just lasts so long it ringers it gets
worse and worse
and there has been like spurts of time
where I have been sober for months
really yeah but how'd you do it
we had you know support groups
you can't stick with it
I mean
I have no one left you know
back then yesterday
they had a girlfriend or a car or
something going for me you know
now I have nothing going for me
so like ugly worthless piece of [__]
I hate myself
I heard my son's voice for the first
time like three months ago
and all I felt was shade
it's not being there
what's your greatest strength
I know you're in a negative mindset
right now with this my greatest strength
um
and somehow I still made it this far
somehow I've still like
even though it gets [__] hard
I'll find a way to get back on my feet
somehow you know
and if I have to [__] sell drugs I'll
sell drugs you know
somehow always then end up back in the
car
you know like I start getting my life
going again but
I think that's like that's all I got and
I gotta stick to that resilience
no matter how much [__] tries to
[__] fly at me just gotta [__]
move on you know
kick it out of the way
gotta stop thinking about suicide
is this your darkest point right now you
think so
I think it is I mean I've thought that
plenty of times because it can get worse
you know there's people out here like
literally two feet away right now and
they have it way worse than me
you don't look like a drug addict really
no you look
like you come from Santa Monica you just
look at a normal kid
almost cut my finger off the other day
somebody attacked me
I had a necklace knife and I try to pull
it out and so [__] sharp I almost cut
my finger off yeah
it's funny because why are people
attacking you
you weren't actually attacking me um
this is a girl I was asking to use her
lighter and this black dude started
trying to hit her you know and I'm not
okay with that I'm not okay with a woman
abuse at all
whatsoever I mean my mother was raped by
her dad as a child my grandmother was
raped by her father as a child
so like that's something that really
[__] bothered me
so I stepped in
I grabbed my blade and I [__] cut him
and uh when I grabbed my blade I cut
yeah I hurt my finger
not really that bad you know considering
what could happen
but yeah that's just like one of those
situations admitted
you know I seem like a normal kid
because like I said
I'm pretty good at
like hiding you know pretending like
like normal person I'm really not
it's hard don't leave me wrong but
are you taking the blame for it I mean
to me hearing your story your family
you're surrounded by drug addicts every
every direction you look yeah
your parents abandon you because of
drugs and then you end up getting taken
in by more drug addicts yeah
what are you supposed to do with your
life I don't know
it's [__] up right
it's pretty bleak
a hell of a witty for a kid to grow up
yeah it's hard
it's hard to be positive
it's hard to like
it's hard to see better for myself
to know what normal is you know
there is a normal
life out there for you
you think so yeah I know so it's just
not going to happen down here yeah [__]
no
Zion mode you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your
23 years
[__] do drugs
I mean like
I regret it every time
I don't care how good it feels
I know that every time I've held my son
every time I help my son
it's felt way better
than any [__] drug
s
and I can't even do that
because I've been blinded
I
one of the [__] drugs
and it's shitty [__] lifestyle
that I chose
I hate myself every day for choosing it
and if I could change anything
I'll change everything
I would have never touched [__]
foreign
let me uh let me give you the name of
somebody
might be able to help you out
okay
thank you so much thank you